got a little bit of a breezy start to
our wednesday and we expect to get
downright windy through the day it's
beautiful outside
sun is on its way up now and we've got
some clouds around
let's check out temperatures and check
out some wind speeds as well
as we look across the valley you can see
there are some clouds around
out there those are going to continue
off and on today
temperatures mainly in the mid to low
60s a few 50s like nellis
centennial hills at 59 kyle canyon has
had
50 plus mile an hour wind gusts every
hour
since midnight it is really windy up in
the mountains
param a few breezes but not too bad at
59
and then some gusty winds at mountain
springs summit between pahrump and las
vegas
kingman at 53 laughlin at 55 red rocket
60.
expect those winds to increase as this
strong
system pushes into the west the rain and
snow into northern and western nevada
and parts of california
we won't get the rain and snow but we
will get the wind today
and that's going to cause temperatures
to actually increase and
even push up near record highs wind
advisory from 10 a.m to 7
p.m for the lake the river uh almost all
of clark county other than this
extreme southern part and central nevada
we're looking at 78 degrees today we
should be 65.
we'll cool off to that later in the
weekend look for 78 down to 71 and sunny
tomorrow
lighter winds more clouds a few breezes
friday and next week looks awesome as we
roll into thanksgiving
67 degrees and good sunshine on to the